let's jump now to the celebrities are
losing their minds yeah story and we'll
go through this one Sam Smith shares
quarantine meltdown on Instagram I don't
care
well we're done thanks for no no I have
some theories about what's wrong with
celebrities plated salmon someone in the
comments was asked I think it was zero
he wants a Tim theory on why they're so
just any any sort of to give it to him
when you are a little kid okay and let's
imagine you're a child actor actress
musician whatever Disney kid you know
everyone in the world keeps telling you
how amazing you are you grow up with his
intense pressure you got to be the best
you got to do this and you're on top of
the world as a little kid you now feel
as you grow up the amount of love and
attention you got from the entire world
you know is baseline yeah not good not
bad normal so what happens when you
become you know a weird-looking adult
and then all of a sudden hmm people
don't give you that much attention
anymore and you go down to slightly you
know below average for you yeah they're
still famous we see these child actors
and actresses go insane starting fires
and driveways throwing bongs out windows
and add that to our conversation
yesterday about you know the the female
versus guys writing exactly like if the
baseline starts here for everybody now
everyone's starting up here like no
matter if you're a guy or girl you know
then it's it's actually even worse for
girls so that gets worse it gets worse
over time yeah these these little these
kids and these celebrities mmm-hmm are
told constantly by everyone how amazing
and smart their because I got money and
power yeah and so they got yes men and
bootlickers all over the place brown
nosers Jim and they're certain noses
scrape the butts and it feels good like
drinkin beer what happens then when you
get locked down in a quarantine yeah all
of a sudden there's no one there to show
you how and guess what dudes crying like
the dude cried apparently oh they took
the picture off of him crying yeah there
was a picture there crying yeah that was
the Daily Mail is a different okay so
apparently
I don't care they say write another song
you're a musician seriously when I'm up
somewhere with my guitar guess what I do
I play guitar and I write a song about
it write a song he's not well thank you
that you floor about sorry
we're both an artist excuse me yes sorry
Laura I told floor beau self that you
know Barbra was gonna stay home and stay
safe I'd cry a lot yeah so for those
that aren't familiar floorball is the
word I use for gender-neutral because if
you're not a man or woman your floor
beau
no no anybody who apps to you is a
non-standard pronoun is for button right
right right
yeah yeah so what you end up with our
people who say I'm gonna make you use
the pronoun I want you to use and my
response is no well here's the problem
if I use your pronoun I could offend
someone else you know I'm gonna try not
to offend you but if I don't say your
pronoun you'll get offended if I do
someone else in the room get offended
and I think it's fair that we avoid
offending everybody so now I'm gonna
call you a floor bow yeah all right
that's fair flora flora bow
I really do I do like it I agree with it
yeah that way you know and it's also
like you can't tell me what to say right
yeah don't tell me what to do but so Sam
Smith apparently had a breakdown but I
think this is my theory right you know
elves are you two right
I don't care you up I think about a
little kid who is a movie star mm-hmm
and then once they start getting older
and go through the awkward phase or
whatever yeah now people aren't saying
nice things to them anymore and it feels
like they're doing something wrong so
youtubers experience this and it's
really funny people youtubers moods are
predictable based on their traffic like
you can go to you loggers Channel look
at their past week of YouTube videos and
you'll see their view counts slowly
going down and then all of a sudden a
video will emerge where they're like I
don't know if I can do this anymore and
they're like it's just been so hard on
me and I'm like struggling with this and
I'm like yeah bro your views have been
going down yeah now it's possible their
views are going down because they were
losing their heart they weren't into it
anymore but in reality this is a known
phenomenon hmm that people are attaching
their success to the amount of the
number associated with their videos the
same is true for these celebrities who
are now freaking out look at this one
this one's funny the quarantine
celebrities
have lost their minds although Will
Ferrell is funny in every single look at
the show this picture look at look at
look how funny his face is his face is
great his face is great he looks funny
right there it looks like he's just like
he probably was like tough his hair up
like oh yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna lean
into this crazy celebrity right yeah I
cannot stand these people you know I I
ate I can't bring myself to unmute the
video listen I I still haven't heard it
I don't know what it sounds like and I
don't want to sound now I hear it I
don't want to do it The Daily Beast
for once nails it calling the video
cursed that cursed imagined sing-along
video from gal gadot is any indication
the quarantine celebs are starting to
lose it thankfully we found some make we
found we found some making things nice
to bounce on making things nice I'm
gonna assume that's Will Ferrell's part
of it just because no no you're just
talking about like no I just want to
believe it alright alright okay
conversation over
okay so you know it's the craziest thing
well first of all this is just so so
awful yeah look man I'm not trying to I
always want to clarify when I when I say
negative things it's not to elicit an
emotional response from someone like
when someone insults you they're trying
to make you get emotional reaction I
might run to that I genuinely detest
this I mean there was a time that I was
affected by people insulting me cuz I
was modeling for a long time and I was
my face was all over the place and I did
certain things that people made fun of
me in I used to get upset about it and
then I realized one day it didn't really
matter what other pieces turned off
right hey look at Sarah Silverman's face
she even knows how cringy it is these
people are like narcissism incarnate you
know it's it's like I could you man
these men it's just the worst people
you've ever met
the absolute worst snooty elitists who
think they're smarter and better than
you and this is why they're celebrities
because they're driven to be in front of
everyone else I was reading this
study that said why is that so many
celebrities are narcissists and it said
if you take a hundred people and you
have 99 of them saying are modest and
you know unsure of themselves important
sometimes or ask for advice they'll say
things like a regular person you know I
made this painting what do you think of
it you think it's good I'm not so sure I
like it yeah the narcissist says
everything I do is amazing everyone
needs to look at me and so they jump out
in front of everyone start dancing
around so everyone can see them yeah and
that's why they become celebrities then
they think well we're special
celebrities let's all get our our let's
all text everybody because everyone will
love us so much if we do this video
together and I'm just like you people
are awful yeah it's just awful it's bad
so but but I really do feel like they
know what they're doing your era is gone
the celebrity is doing these silly
things mm-hmm like they got a text
message together and said hey everybody
let's all do this thing to people like
they think they're this special thing
you're not you're just weird people
you're arrogant and narcissistic and
bored and bored too much money they're
bored too much time they're used to
having strict schedules for movies and
then they have like two months off where
they're like oh I am off I can travel to
some exotic place not all of them I
don't know like some of them are not
really doing much right now well then
why are they going crazy if they're not
doing much because they're narcissists
who are used to having everyone shove
their noses up their butts
now they're locked in their house saying
like imagine imagine this way imagine if
every day you went to a meeting and like
ten people walked up and start sniffing
your butt you'd be used to it to be
normal and then one day you're at home
you're under quarantine
and no one's sniff your butt yeah you're
gonna be like dude I need to go on
Twitter I get some people started in my
butt and I'm tweeting and posting this
dumb stuff thinking that now people are
gonna give you that attention you want
yeah I bet these people go through their
mentions and like read every single one
I mean everybody likes attention
everybody
and that's not true I don't know I don't
agree with that no there are people who
are introverted and don't like being the
center of attention in some ways they
like attention somewhere I think people
like being respected like they like
social acceptance and approval okay so
another way of saying it
so something happened to these people
not all of them like I think Will
Ferrell's alright you know he's a funny
guy seems cool but I think a lot of
these celebrities something happened to
them when they were young where they
like didn't ever get fulfilled or like
their parents never told them like
you're doing a good job or something
okay it's like the stereotype of like
the mom like with a little girl and
she's always yelling at her like you
have to act harder and sing better but
no trying no go harder it's like no
matter what she doesn't ever good enough
okay then when she's older it's this she
needs she needs everyone to be tweeting
at her you're the best I love you're so
great otherwise they feel like they've
done something wrong
instead of saying about child actors
yeah yeah if you grow up and you're on
stage and you're you're you know
everyone's clapping and cheering for you
what happens then when your show is over
like what was that chick from all that
and then she had her own to the Amanda
amanda Bynes oh she went crazy
I think she's doing okay go crazy oh
yeah she like started a fire in a
driveway seriously yeah she was on all
that when she was young and then she had
her own show called The Amanda Show and
that's actually where that dude drake
from drake and josh got his start to and
he got his own the show okay you know
Jake and Josh it's like a kid's sitcom I
don't know man it's just like Disney
Channel stuff people know that I'm sorry
wait no no TV no I don't want okay
anyway the point is no she was a she was
young she's on the show she had her own
show and then all of a sudden as time
went on charts going crazy like Lindsay
Lohan - oh yeah I'm it's like yeah as
they get older and they're no longer
like Britney Spears she went crazy -
didn't she I don't know about that word
I don't know I don't know I remember a
time where she went that was because of
drug testing drug test she was getting
dirty wanted to take her kid away so I
don't know the full story stressful they
wanted to do a hair test so she shaved
her head off so they couldn't do a hair
test because they were gonna because she
had you know long hair ten years of hair
yeah okay so I don't I don't know the
full story so I don't want to I don't
wanna I'm not gonna slam I don't know
anything about it I'm kidding um but I'm
not here to defend you know Britney
Spears whatever the point is okay yeah a
lot of them go through these weird
breakdowns where they lose it and they
go nuts yeah it reminds me of you ever
see the movie Dogma yeah when Bethany in
the beginning says that when she was
younger she had a glass that was full of
faith but as she got it she got older
the glass got bigger but you don't have
faith going into that glass
was never enough to fill it and I don't
remember it very well but that's the
analogy she owes like when you're little
you have you have a small glass that you
fill with water it's really easy to fill
in a little bit yeah but as you get
older in your glass it becomes bigger
you need more and more to give you that
feeling that's what it's like when so
like to go back to the youtubers thing
mm-hmm every if everyday are youtubers
views isn't a little bit better yeah
they they feel bad like oh no I need to
do better every day it's impossible just
guess they don't get that dopamine kick
yup so people are going on these
dopamine retreats where they're like
they don't talk detoxing from dopamine
and then when they come out of it it's
like everything's amazing again it's
like yeah it's almost like if you don't
drop acid and don't do that family show
don't do that I'm just talking about
it's also fasting like if you if you
just if you if you don't if you don't
eat for a day mm-hmm the next day
everything tastes better yeah she's like
you got it you got it you got a relaxed
man that's true these people couldn't
let it go they couldn't take one
quarantine to do nothing they had to be
alike but we must be the center of
attention let's all sing the Beatles and
everyone's making fun of him for it good
we should be made fun of you've got your
weird people well they're getting their
attention aren't they I mean we are too
so I mean Who am I to speak right we
have a show whatever
yeah that's true mom we got 9,000 people
hanging out with us right now
so yeah my dopamine is through the roof
no but but admittedly like we had we had
11,000 yesterday and the day before yeah
there's another thousand today I don't
care
yeah I'm glad you everyone's here and
yeah exactly if people want to believe
I'd be like well you know can't win them
all right tomorrow up do your best carry
on and don't be a whiny little baby
because you didn't want in your soul
mate thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next show
you